so can you just talk about like what
life looks like for you now with
quadruplets he has been to the circus
hello everybody we're the gardener's and
we have quadruplet three-year-old little
girls so when Ashley and I got married
we both knew that we want to have a big
family I'm the oldest of ten Ashley's
the youngest of five and when we decided
to start trying to have children it was
just part of a dream that we had a
vision we were patient in the beginning
we didn't really worry too much about it
we were young and we were still enjoying
life going into that first year of
trying we started to have some doubts
and we were beginning to be frustrated
so we decided to go to several different
doctors and we were just trying to
figure out what's going on I kind of
self diagnosed myself with in Demetrios
as' I had done some research and I
pretty much knew that I had all of these
symptoms no one would believe me and so
several years passed and we went to
several different doctors and they just
said well we don't know why just keep
trying and it was super frustrating it
was about 6 years in that we finally
found a doctor that agreed with me that
I had endometriosis and sent me to a
surgeon who did a laparoscopy surgery
that's the only way you can see if you
have endometriosis as if they go in
physically and look at it when she went
in for the surgery she predicted that I
probably had about a stage 2
endometriosis and when she got out of
the surgery she realized I had a stage 3
borderline for endometriosis and that
means that basically I just have scar
tissue all over my reproductive organs
which was keeping us from getting
pregnant she cleaned out as much as she
could and and gave us the best chances
of getting pregnant on her own at that
point we tried for another year and we
still didn't get pregnant we started to
look into adoption and I just had this
really strong gut feeling that I just
needed to try IVF one time both of them
are very expensive time consuming a lot
goes into that process and so you know
making that decision for us was one of
the hardest decisions that we had to
make at that time you know a lot of
infertility is not covered by insurance
and so we knew we were kind of on her
own so we decided to go in and tell our
doctor we were ready to do IVF we had
saved up the money for it that is not an
easy process to do at all it is very
draining I mean you're giving yourself
shots every single day it's extremely
painful to go through we got through the
process
all of our eggs ended up not making it
except for the two so they put the two
back and we waited he gave us a 40%
chance of having one baby
those were the the odds that they gave
us so I mean that was a very very
emotional and tough day for both of us
if this didn't work we were just gonna
go on to adoption which was going to be
great during that time we had a lot of
fears and doubts that were starting to
creep in that we were just gonna have
one and I wanted to have twins at least
I was praying for twins we go in for the
ultrasound and she starts looking and
she immediately sees two sacks and she
goes oh you guys have twins we were
amazed we were so pumped and she goes
wait hold on a second she keeps getting
closer and closer to the screen and I
looked at Tyson and honestly my first
thought was oh my gosh like one or both
of them don't have heartbeats
and it felt like an eternity before she
finally was like there's four in there
and I was like oh my gosh is this real
life I mean I'd never known anybody who
had had quadruplets before I was so
excited because this was it for us
and like we're gonna get our whole
family but it's my body able to do this
are the babies gonna be okay
obviously coming out of that ultrasound
like we didn't even know which way to
turn this was something I mean so
unexpected luckily for us both of our
families live close our brothers or
sisters are here our parents and we
relied on them heavily the pregnancy
just kind of was a whirlwind from there
you don't really have time to sit back
and enjoy the moment of jeez we're
having quadruplets let's think about
this for a minute I mean you just go go
go go go the doctors want to see you
every week it is a high-risk pregnancy
and they want to check and look at those
babies as much as they can
everything had looked great and all the
babies were growing perfectly their
heartbeats were perfect everything was
great I went in at 20 weeks for an
appointment and everything went
completely the opposite direction they
had been watching for something called
TTTS
which is twin to twin transfusion
syndrome when TTTS happens it means that
their blood vessels have fused together
and they're sharing nutrition which is
fine as long as they keep sharing it
back and forth and as me had given all
of the nutrients to ND and indi wasn't
passing any of it back and so this means
that indy had
ton of fluid around her to the point
where her heart was beating overtime as
she was about to go into heart failure
and as me we couldn't even see her
individual sac that she was in it was
suction cup to her body and they
couldn't find a bladder on her so she
was technically starving to death we
found out that day that there are
incredible doctors who do these
life-saving fetal surgeries no one in
Utah did it so we had to fly to LA to
get a surgery from an incredible doctor
there he drained a liter of fluid off of
Indy's sac which was a ton for a little
tiny baby they use a laser and they
separate the blood vessels so this
surgery was either going to work and it
was going to save all of these babies
lives or it was going to cost so much
trauma that I was going to just deliver
and we would have lost them all and
there was just a 50/50 chance and we
just had to go with it and go with our
faith in prayer that everything was
going to be okay
they did the surgery we waited 24 hours
we went and did another ultrasound and
all four of these little miracle babies
had survived that very traumatic surgery
and we flew back home and I was on bed
rest from then until I delivered so an
average day for us is the girls wake up
about eight o'clock and we wake up we
bring them downstairs we cook them all
breakfast and you try and get
two-year-olds to eat which they don't me
as a paranoid mom I'm always running
around with like snacks and fruit and
just eat something we always try to do
an activity in the morning whether it's
a park or yeah we go out taking them on
a little shopping trip to where they can
get out and run their energy out so yeah
that's what we do and then we come home
we eat lunch and the girls go down for a
nap still we are lucky with that not all
two-year-olds almost three-year-olds nap
that's when we entice and where then
they wake up and we just play and do
dinner and then play more do bath time
and then it's off to bed and then the
end dad work again you know when the
babies were born it was just such a
miracle honestly I think God just looked
out for us he blessed us every step of
the way he really did I mean every
doctor we've come in contact with has
said your girls shouldn't be they
shouldn't be healthy or you know some of
them made shouldn't have even been here
they truly are miracles and they have a
purpose for being here because they have
defied every odd that was thrown at them
I mean when they were born Indy was
smallest and she got down to one pound 6
ounces she just fit in the palm of your
hand
they were so strong and we had
incredible doctors and staff for those
of you guys who are still struggling
with infertility there are definitely
times when you don't think it's going to
end and there's definitely times when
you lose your faith just keep putting
one foot in front of the other and take
it one step at a time you just have to
remember that everything is going to be
ok and your story is going to be
beautiful just for you and it's going to
turn out the exact way that it is
supposed to for you all right so these
are our quadruplet daughters and as you
can see sometimes you have to bribe them
a little bit or you got to get on your
horse
show me how you rock yeah
[Applause]
[Music]